foreign
[Music]
hello everybody Welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua Phillips Wilburn
and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together
we're the minimalists we got malabama
here hi everybody TK Coleman Holly Jolly
Christmas
in April
Christmas every day of my heart oh man
we got the rest of our team here in the
studio as well and coming up today on
this free public minimal episode we're
talking about a rather contentious
subject monogamy and
non-monogamy a subject about which your
three hosts have three different
viewpoints And to clarify things we're
adding a fourth perspective from an
expert joining us in the studio today is
Aubry Marcus Aubry is an author
podcaster entrepreneur filmmaker
philosopher poet and husband
do you find Value in this conversation
you can check out the full three hour
maximal edition of Episode 385 with
Aubry Marcus where we answer five times
the questions and we dive deep into
several simple living segments that
private podcast episode is out right now
at patreon.com the minimalists your
support keeps our podcasts and both of
our YouTube channels 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck we'll start with our
callers here in a moment so if you have
a question or a comment for our show
give us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice recording
to podcast at developmentalists.com but
first we have a question from ivaross on
Facebook
oh dear a conversation about monogamy
and open relationships is that even
legal I thought such explosive stuff was
for confessional only I find this topic
very surprising in the context of
minimalism why choose a personal trainer
to dissect the pros and cons of
promiscuity wow wow I didn't even know I
was a personal trainer so thank you
thank you for that Accolade I didn't
deserve however I appreciate it it's
just he's like really handsome and fit
of Men's Health Magazine and so I
trained myself personally yeah I suppose
so there we go that's kind of like
saying why are you having a model talk
about this okay
I found that judgment is the fastest way
to shut down a conversation so we put
out a call for our listeners to send in
questions about this and this one was
fascinating to me me because there are
some assumptions here of course when you
talk about Aubry Mark as you could say
entrepreneur you can say husband you can
say you know a uh a podcaster author
whatever and someone says well here's a
really fit guys I'm going to call him a
a personal trainer but then I'm also
going to say to talk about the pros and
cons of promiscuity and that's a word
with a lot of baggage associated with it
as well I'm gonna let Aubry talk here
because I'm really fascinated in his
perspective but the reason I wanted to
have you on the podcast today to talk
about this is you've gone through quite
the transformation Journey yourself
someone who seemed to be really into
polyamory and and being having multiple
partners and then have found yourself in
a monogamous relationship and I don't
even know what your current status is
and I thought maybe you could walk us
through that journey and having a deeper
understanding of what it means to be in
relationship with someone else
I mean this is a huge question
relationship is a central core part of
our life like that dyad that we have
typically it's a dyad now there's some
other different constellations that do
exist but typically it's a dyad between
two people that forms like the core
nucleus that we build our lives around
to a great degree and sometimes we don't
have that and we're single and there's
many different ways to do it but that
dyad is a core tenet of our life so how
to organize the structure around that is
something that's very important and I
think we've been given this default
model which is you got to be monogamous
and it's got to be this way and this is
what you got to do it's like basically
downloading the contract from LegalZoom
when you start your company and saying
oh yeah it's perfect just as it is no
modifications necessary right and that's
the way that we really have been kind of
told in the mainstream about what we're
supposed to do and sometimes that works
sometimes the LegalZoom contract works
just right and it's just exactly as you
want but I think we're all you Unique
Individuals with unique desires and
we're facing some different trends that
are happening in the aggregate so if you
look at some of the trends that are
happening in the aggregate you can look
at Dr Wednesday Martin's book untrue and
in there she charts graphs of sexual
desire and the amount of times that
people have sex with each other in
marriage and what you see is typically
after two or three years
for the men that starts to decline their
sexual desire towards their partner
starts to decline slowly on a kind of
ever descending graph and for women
actually it falls off a cliff and it
just the graph goes up and then it just
drops and this is why we get all of
those memes about when a man is wants to
have sex with his wife I hope I get
lucky tonight maybe I'll get lucky
tonight right like we have this in the
Zeitgeist that somehow the woman doesn't
want to make love to her husband and
actually in the aggregate that pans out
so we're seeing that there's an issue
now either you can just say this is just
life this is how it works if you're in
this thing this is what you can expect
no worries and you can normalize that or
you can say no I'm not going to accept
that I want to adjust the agreement or
layer in new technology that I can use
in my love making that will actually
change that Dynamic so those were the
two choices now the first first choice I
made was to adjust the agreement and I
adjusted the agreement by entering into
a polyamorous container with my partner
Whitney
that was unbelievably difficult I cannot
express to you how difficult that was
and of course you can lob your insults
and accusations and I promise you it has
a lot more to do with it than
promiscuity this is the pain and torture
of knowing that your sweetheart the one
that you love is just as free to go out
and be with another man as you are free
to be with another woman and we all had
we both had several lovers during that
period but it was incredibly challenging
so it was really a path of evolution and
self-transformation but what we were
doing is in the access to other partners
the novelty right of like being with
somebody new sparked what the technical
term is is limerence which is that new
relationship energy where Everything
feels fresh and exciting because what
you're doing is You're encountering The
Stranger in a new person so for me it
was another face of the Goddess it was
another woman that I could actually see
and learn about and understand and see
how she saw me and see my reflection in
her and give her a reflection through me
and that process was beautiful and my
paramours as they're called they lasted
one was like six years or three years or
four years these were deep relationships
that coincided with my primary
partnership with Whitney who was
actually my fiance
but through that it was incredibly
challenging because at certain points
that limerence that new relationship
energy it will actually make it feel
like you're no longer the primary
partner because they're so excited about
their new she was so excited about her
new boyfriend or I was so excited about
my new girlfriend that you were like
yeah you're my queen and you're my king
and we're in primary partnership but
really secretly we're just thinking
about these other people because that's
the new relationship that's the
limerence energy
so it worked to keep passion alive but
it was ultimately incredibly difficult
and after eight years of that Journey on
in polyamory
it was it got the better of me I just
had to actually wave the white flag and
say like I can't do this so Whitney and
I ended up splitting up and then I was
basically single for a period of time
even though Whitney and I would still
you know we're still entangled and we'd
still see each other but it got the
better of me I ultimately couldn't
handle her being in love with other men
and I did my best and and I got better
at it for sure from the first time she
had a lover to the last time she had a
lover I was definitely more seasoned
more equipped
but I got the better of me I was never
able to actually fully honestly be okay
and so there was lots of positive things
on the other side it had amazing great
relationships and I was actually able to
meet my wife and we didn't start a
relationship but I was able to have the
freedom to meet my wife and hang out
with her because we were in a
polyamorous container now it took many
years after meeting her before we
actually got together
but when I got together with vilana then
I was finished with polyamory and I was
like you're the one we got married in a
matter of months and I was absolutely
sure I was like I want to be with you
the rest of my life and I trusted that
during that period I'd also learned new
technology and the new technology was
how do you encounter The Stranger in the
same person over and over how do you
find novelty at depth rather than
novelty in variety and breadth so
finding the stranger inside of her
every single time you know maybe not
this exaggeration but you know as many
times as we apply this technology this
tantric technology finding the stranger
in my same wife and that evokes that
same level of passion so all those
graphs that I talked about in Dr
Wednesday Martin's book those are going
to be the things untrue not the title of
her book because we're going to be the
outlier and that's the life that I'm
living now three years in wow yeah
that's awesome
and what does that have to do with
minimalism if it's not already clear
I'll let you know minimalism is not
about luxury goods and moving boxes and
other things that we stuff away in a
storage facility it's about dealing with
the things that weigh us down and hold
us back from living the healthiest kind
of life we can live and so if you've got
relationship clutter or psychological
clutter philosophical clutter you can
have a house empty of things and still
be weighed down and everything that
aubry's talking about right now is about
relationship clutter the stories we tell
about ourselves the stories we tell
ourselves about how we relate to one
another and the process that he went
through to downsize some things that was
hurting him and making the quality of
his life worse but tki just to piggyback
on that the reason I wanted to have
Aubry here is I knew he would be talking
about this without a particular Dogma I
could talk to someone who is in a
monogamous relationship and they say
well actually the right relationship is
between one man and one woman and even
when you look at monogamy we we can talk
about what monogamy is like true
monogamy and the truest sense of the
word is two people meet when they're
both are virgins and they spend their
entire life together right and so most
people who are advocating for monogamy
aren't even advocating for that kind of
monogamy it's more about serial monogamy
or being with one person at a time with
no overlap and so when we're talking
about this subject I want to talk to you
because you obviously have some
experience here on both sides and you
talked about the pain and the torture of
being in an open relationship can you
elaborate a bit more on that
well yes I mean it was both pain and
torture and absolute ecstasy right I
mean it was both of those and you can't
really talk about one without the other
there's the Elation of being with those
new partners and there's the Elation of
actually what they call Reclamation
energy when your partner's been with
somebody else and you come back together
and you try and it's like you're trying
to you know fuse your energy field so
deeply that all memory of past lovers
goes away right it's like you try to
smash together and it's like push out
any memory of of anybody that they've
been with so there's a lot of passion
there but fundamentally there's a lot of
reinforced perhaps biologically
definitely
sociological jealousy that's there you
know if your partner loves somebody else
if your partner wants to sleep with
somebody else there's some internal
deficiency with you remember the first
lover my partner had was a professional
fighter and
it was it was really brutal because I
thought like okay if she's gonna love me
I gotta become a better fighter so I got
in the gym and I was like training hard
and then one day I was like you're a
idiot you're never gonna be
anywhere as good as this guy he will
beat you up a thousand times out of a
thousand so what are you even doing you
know and it was like I had to ultimately
this was one of the lessons I had to
trust that Whitney loved Aubry for Aubry
and the only thing I could do was be the
most Aubry that I could possibly be so
it was a lesson in self-love but through
the process I felt deficient I felt less
than I felt like I was not good enough
and it didn't matter what guy she was
with even if it was a guy that partied
more than me and was free more available
for that type of expression of energy
I'd be like I just work too hard I'm a
loser I'm always working I don't have
the time to party with my sweetheart and
be with her like he does and of course
she loves him more than me you know he
just didn't have a job
like he was a good guy but like but
fundamentally I would try to compete
with everything they have to relearn
that lesson over and over and then they
would have an experience that was really
intense either sexually or romantically
and then I'd be like have we had an
experience like that like when was the
last time that happened with us like
what it was so brutal yeah did you ever
find yourself uh like trying to one-up
each other because it sounds like every
time she okay yeah I mean that's a
really toxic expression of how to handle
it and we did our best not to do that
um but you know I I imagine that there
was some of that in there right like and
certainly if one of us was with somebody
else the other one would make sure that
they would be with one of their Partners
too right like we tried we tried it was
very difficult to just be sitting at
home twiddling our thumbs being like ah
hope they're having a good time
I really hope it's going well and
sometimes we would we would read like
really gracious and like they would be
at a hotel and I'd call in and I'd order
champagne for them as like an honor of
like look I honor that you're gonna
enjoy yourself and she would do the same
for me and we would try our best but it
wasn't always fully available to us and
in some ways Whitney did a better job
than me in in some regards as far as
being able to deal with it I was I'm
just a more emotional creature and it
was it was really tough and so you
struggled in this relationship you also
experienced great pleasure and ecstasy
and joy and a lot of growth it sounds
like as well
and yet it seems to me that other people
in a similar scenario don't have those
same struggles and so maybe you could
talk about from your exposure to people
who are in open relationships that seem
to be thriving maybe they don't have
that same level of jealousy or of
discontent in the real in fact it could
for some people be mostly upside is that
right
yes I don't see that that often to be
honest I see because I don't think that
the cultural structure is there to
really support it so it's what's
difficult is is that when you expose
this idea to your friend group there's
going to be people with the conventional
model and the conventional idea that
will ask questions and be suspicious and
kind of implant ideas that kind of
undermines the structure I actually do
think that the structure can work and it
does work for some people you know for
sure you're absolutely right about that
it's difficult though because culturally
it's not fully supported and the
Consciousness is not at a level where
we're able to actually handle it so
those who are making it work are
genuinely evolutionary pioneers and they
really have cultivated a strong
community and so just the utmost respect
for anybody who's really making that
work because it is a challenging path
but it's an unbelievable path of growth
like unbelievable so I still can
recommend this path if you want to learn
about yourself and you want to deal and
grapple with these emotional forces that
your own possessiveness your own
jealousy your own self-love you you walk
this path you'll be a better person for
having been broken time and time again
and having to put yourself back together
so that's how that's what I really think
about I think about it as a path for
growth and for some people potentially
they can make it a sustainable path I
just haven't seen it that often work in
that way yeah it's funny because I think
about if someone wants to go down this
path you really got to question your
intentions like why do you want to go
down this path because for me when I
hear about polyamory I'm like oh yeah
that sounds great I would love to have
different partners but that is like the
high testosterone to me like speaking to
my yeah to my to my body so um yeah I
don't think I would be successful in it
honestly and I'm also surprised that I
can even have this conversation right
now because like 10 years ago uh maybe
not 10 or 15 years ago go I was like
really hardcore Jehovah's Witness
Christian and I would have not have even
entertained this conversation but um but
I'm glad we're having it well it's
interesting you say that because I found
when we put out a call for questions
about this a lot of people have that
knee-jerk reaction because they assume
it's this weird sort of binary it's
either monogamy or it is chaos and
there's chaos in either one of these by
the way and you there can be order in
fact there are some terms we're gonna be
talking about today when we get to some
of our callers here which we'll get to
in a second because
monogamy and non-monogamy there's a
whole as we were doing photos downstairs
or you're like there's a whole world in
between there and so I thought maybe we
would address a bit of that let's move
on to some of our callers here Professor
Sean we have an anonymous caller
in the non-monogamy world there's a
pretty large acceptance of the term
compersion Loosely it's explained is
feeling pleasure from someone else's
pleasure even if you're not directly
benefiting and applied even more
genuinely among the group that
identifies ethical non-monogamous
although this is quite a juxtaposition
concept for people who believe that the
terms ethical and non-monogamy can't be
placed together my question is for
someone who experiences conversion to a
fault being that they continue to
prioritize other people's pleasure over
themselves to the point of feeling that
it's more difficult to accept care from
others than give care even if it's not
hurting them or sacrificing their own
well-being but it does isolate them and
also hurt the people who want to give
care how can that person create a
healthier relationship with their own
needs or wants that directly benefit
themselves and begin to heal the belief
that no one will care or take care of
them really consistently and due to that
pain the answer was to care for others
unconditionally and never let that be
the case for people they care about
because they themselves had never
experienced it
and to a fault continue the cycle of
fear and rejection by not allowing good
people to prove the belief wrong and
times when this person has tried to be
vulnerable they find the reality that
people are imperfect and that that is
good and okay but still feels unsafe
acknowledging that this is largely due
to confirmation bias also for context
some people with deductive reasoning
would wonder if this person has a
passive abuse and that would be correct
but in traditional CBT therapy the
concept of non-monogamy is not widely
accepted making this topic difficult to
see seek perspective on for this person
personally through their experiences and
overcoming their past and reaching for
healing and love they found Hope and
acceptance among people who do not shame
complex sexuality that comes from broken
past they have learned to accept that
overcoming trauma does change a person
and the paths to healing and
self-acceptance do not always look
conventional
I think the key word here is complex
let's get some terms out onto the table
here she talked briefly about compersion
and that's something that comes up a lot
in non-monogamous relationships it's
almost like an introductory word for
people right I've always used it to
describe my relationship with my
daughter because like whenever she
experiences Joy it feels contagious it's
like real joy and I notice that in
people around me so you can talk about
conversion in a non-sexual or intimate
absolute way but it tends to be used in
these ethically non-monogamous
relationships which that term by itself
also drives me a little bit crazy
because there's plenty of ethical
monogamous relationships but plenty of
non or unethical monogamous
relationships as well if having to use
that term that way presupposes that
monogamy is inherently ethical and
therefore non-monogamous relationships
are inherently unethical but that
doesn't seem to be the case the the
bigger problem that our Anonymous caller
is talking about here is some of the the
fear and the rejection which you've
expressed a bit as well what insights do
you have for her
well yeah I mean I think talking about
ethical non-monogamy there was never a
more ethical relationship up to date
than my polyamorous relationship because
the honesty was at exactly a hundred
there was not a single thing that we had
to hide from each other or would hide so
another term for that is kitchen table
polyamory where everything is out in the
open all of the partners are able to
talk to each other there's no secrets
there's nothing hidden it's radical
hundred percent truth and 100 percent
permission and that is actually rare in
most monogamous relationships that I've
encountered even if actions aren't taken
thoughts cannot be shared because the
thoughts are too volatile and chaotic
and dangerous to share if you find
somebody attractive if you feel yourself
feeling something well you can't share
that that's not part of the agreement so
you stuff that in and you keep that
little bit secret from your partner so I
found that that this style of
relationship with the radical permission
allows you to have an even higher
standard of Ethics because there's
nothing that you can't share nothing you
can't talk about and we've I've
replicated that in my now monogamous
relationship with my wife because that
was a prerequisite I wanted there to be
radical communication and conversation
if either of us were attracted to
anybody we don't have to do anything
about it but we got to share it there's
nothing that I want her to feel like she
needs to keep secret from me and there's
nothing that I want to keep secret from
her so that standard of honesty was
another thing that polyamory taught me
so then going to conversion conversion
is always the goal I wanted to feel the
Ecstasy that my partner felt when she
was in sexual relation with another
person
I just couldn't do it right and I think
a lot of people would make accusations
of me oh Aubry you know Norris the
beta you know who's enjoying
cuckolding is a fantasy where you
actually enjoy the idea of another man
sleeping with your partner I don't have
that Kink it's just not in me at all
yeah some people would compliment you
for not having that right yeah it's like
that I mean and and praise be to those
who have it because that makes things a
lot easier I'm sure right because it's
like they're being aroused by their
partner's arousal with another person
for me I didn't have that so it was a
matter of love and Consciousness and I
could touch it at certain points but it
was very difficult for me to maintain it
and so conversion again we're all
familiar with compassion
the etymology of compassion is to be
with someone in their suffering
compersion the etymology is to be with
somebody in their pleasure right to
really be with somebody in their
pleasure and to do that is to actually
not be looking at them separately is to
be on the inside of their pleasure and
so yes this can happen sexually in a
sexual situation for sexual pleasure but
it happens all the time like I think you
can tell a good friend of yours if a
good friend experiences something
amazing then you feel all of the
pleasure and joy and potentially even
more pleasure and joy than that person
feels I remember with good friends of
mine that were Fighters you know one of
my best friends in the world is Aaron
Rodgers a football player I remember
when he beat the Cowboys last year and I
was there at the game like the feeling
that I felt because was like probably
more elated than he even felt in that
moment and that's conversion it's like
really being with somebody in that
sensation the caller mentioned some
things that were you know kind of
conflating this type of relating to a
trauma pattern or things like that I
think that's an oversimplification and
while that may be the case
sometimes this is just a choice and a
solution for somebody who is dealing
with this idea like I don't want to live
in a sexually passionless life I don't
have the tantric technology to find the
stranger Anew in my partner so I'm going
to engage in this practice because I
want to be honest I'm not willing to be
unfaithful so I'm going to engage in
this out of my own volition and that was
my path I've had a beautiful
relationship with my mother and pretty
much every woman on down the line I had
a pretty sketchy girlfriend in college
one time but other than that it's been
like epic right so it's not a wounding
thing with the feminine and it's not
about me like wanting to claim trophies
I don't give a about that like
every person I wanted to be with I
wanted to go as deep as I could until I
could see the inner core of who they
were and share that relation so the idea
that this is some kind of trauma bonding
or trauma-driven thing to me that's just
false it's just not true and I'm I'm the
outline I mean I'm the exception to that
idea and I don't know if that's exactly
what she was saying but it seemed to
have that kind of implication well
there's also something about empathy
that's in this question and I think
empathy is a bit of a bell curve they're
suffering on both ends if you have no
empathy at all for anyone ever that can
either call suffering or it could be
that there's some sort of trauma
associated with that you've shut off all
empathy but the other side of the bell
curve is if you're feeling all the
empathy you're feeling the pain so the
etymology of empathy means to also feel
their suffering right and so to feel the
suffering not just be with them but
suffering but to feel that suffering is
true empathy if you have intense really
turned up empathy well what happens you
are also going to suffer by definition
you have to suffer and so I think maybe
part of that was um I'm speaking for you
at this point but in your relationship
there was suffering there the two of you
were sharing when you were in a
polyamorous relationship and so the
suffering can become contagious
yeah it can and it's
um you know you have to and I think she
was also a bit concerned about somebody
over giving of themselves to give
somebody pleasure and then not feeling
the pleasure themself it's not
conversion if you're not with them in
their pleasure so the whole concept that
you're gonna give somebody pleasure but
not feel it that's not conversion that's
self-sacrifice that's a whole different
thing right like it's a much different
thing if you're actually in conversion
you're both elevating your state of
pleasure you know it's not like it's not
like you're giving them this and it's
costing you something no you're sharing
in this in this state of emotional
activation and aliveness yeah I think
empathy is one hell of a drug and when
it becomes a drug it can really turn on
you I mean when you experience someone
else's pain
um you're doing them a service and they
will show you like oh thanks for being
with me and my pain and that feels good
so it's easy to get caught up in doing
things for others I because that's what
I kind of heard from the caller was that
someone gets caught up in empathy and
they really don't focus on their own uh
pain or Joy because they're so caught up
in reflecting someone else's pain so I
mean empathy like we put on this
pedestal and I think that empathy is a
great thing to have we all need it but
when it becomes a drug like it can it
can it really hold us back especially
with the situation she's talking about
about people who are abused and have
these wounds that are trying to heal
because you come from that background
where you've been abused like you're
used to feeling bad about yourself and
that's like in a weird way it's security
it's like you know if you do a certain
thing you're gonna feel bad about
yourself and you'd rather you know have
the double you know than the the W you
don't know
yeah and you take away that conversion
it introduces so many unhealthy elements
in the relationship like if I'm making
sacrifices for you and I see myself as
I'm doing you a favor right right you're
keeping score there you go yeah I have
that martyrdom syndrome and then I
resent you can conversion be cultivated
yes it can it can and it's a technology
again and I keep using the word
technology because these are psycho
Technologies I think we try to reduce
our technology to like what's the new
Apple update on the phone that's one
type of technology in the material realm
but psycho technologies have been being
cultivated by many cultures for
thousands of years from the Hebrew
kabbalist lineage which I've entered as
a part of to the Mahayana Buddhist
lineage to the Taoist lineages to all of
the tantric lineages to so many more
lineages that have cultivated psycho
Technologies either for meditative
practices going inside to emotional
practices of how you actually enter a
state where you can join someone in
their emotional frequency right these
are technologies that can be cultivated
and part of it is to be able to clear
yourself of any jealousies clear
yourself of any judgments clear yourself
of anything that's withholding you and
then with volition with intention enter
into their emotional state of rapture
Joy ecstasy and to do that you have to
you have to really eliminate all of the
comparison and all of the jealousy
anything like that that you're feeling
and then be willing to surrender any
aspect of your own ego identity and just
jump in with them jump into the Waters
of where they're at and meet them there
and it's a skill that can be cultivated
as we wrap up this question I was hoping
maybe you could talk a bit about the
tantric technology that you're
experiencing in your own marriage now
and how you understand that and how you
use it regularly yeah
so I'm currently working on a project
with a teacher Dr Rabbi Mark Gaffney and
it's called the phenomenology of Eros
and the phenomenology virus goes through
seven different levels of sexual
relating
and in those seven different levels
there's different technologies that you
can use to actually encounter somebody
in a new and deeper way and actually use
your sexuality to reach parts of you
that are different everything from
healing sexing where the idea isn't just
the vital sexing which is level one just
like the animality of the experience and
just that thing that you see in all of
the all of the movies where someone pins
someone up against the wall and they're
making out and then it's on to the
kitchen table and things are crashing
around like that's great you know and
that's one way to do it but it's not
going to be all the time so like healing
sexing is actually going in and going
real slow feeling where there's any
places where there's any trauma that's
still left in the body and applying the
at the right amount of love the right
amount of questions asking what you know
what do you need right now what is this
like what does this touch feel like and
of course some of it is intuitive and
you're really working together other for
that other parts involve you know what
is what we call personality sexing which
includes sexual Theater which is all of
the dominant and submissive play so
you're playing out different roles for
example and in those different roles you
get to encounter an element of your
partner that isn't normally available
there like one of the old Technologies
of wearing a mask whether it was Comedia
Del Arte or whether it was something
else is the mask allows you to embody
some aspect that you normally wouldn't
embody the new identity it's a new
identity so you take on a new identity
and through that new identity a part of
you gets to flourish and flower and then
you get to relate to a part of them
through your different identity so it's
really two strangers meaning you have
different names you have different roles
you have different polarities than your
normal polarity and that's incredibly
Rich you know portal to go in and
there's other different portals that you
can actually enter into Within intention
that illuminate different aspects of
your partner welcome back to the
minimalists Ryan what time is it you
know what time it is it's time for the
lightning round where we answer your
questions from Tick Tock you can follow
the minimalist on Tick Tock Instagram
Facebook and Twitter at the minimalist
during the lightning round we each have
60 seconds to answer your question with
a short shareable less than 140
character response we put the text to
these minimal maxims and the show notes
over at the minimalist.com podcast so
you can copy and share our pithy answers
on social media if you like and we have
a question today from anonymous
it's a lot to ask for one person to be
your everything love is Limitless why
put a limit on how much of it you can
give or receive now TK I know when this
question is asked we often talk about
love I don't think we know what we're
talking about when we talk about love
most of the time we use that word
colloquially and I get it quite often we
say love what we're really saying is I
like it very much yeah oh I love this
new microphone yeah no that's not what
we're talking about we talk about love
we talk about love it's to see someone
for who they are without trying to
change them and without trying to
manipulate them persuade them convince
them drag them to my point of view but
quite often when we're talking about
love
we're talking about our attachment to
someone else our clinging to someone
else
and I would posit that clinging actually
blocks love it gets in the way now Ryan
you had a bit of a different view on
this question or maybe a more nuanced
view on this question it seems like this
person may be in an open relationship or
a poly relationship which potentially
are potentially two different things
here so what were your thoughts on on
the meaning of this question well it
seems to me like they're trying to make
an excuse to hoard love
and to have an excess of Love which
um I think when you have that attitude
towards love eventually
um it is going to feel like hoarding
it's I mean especially when you take a
measurement to it can I read my answer
yeah 60 seconds on the clock Prof
so there is no measuring stick for love
to love someone is to see them
appreciate them and accept them for who
they are warts and all and as soon as
you start to measure love as soon as you
start to keep track of what one person
does for another what they did for me
it's a losing game yes you will start to
get you will start to Harbor resentment
because eventually you're going to feel
that that it's off balance one way or
the other so to love someone whether
it's monogamy or non-monogamy that love
can be endless it doesn't matter if it's
one person or many people I think
there's a there's a deep well when it
comes to love and we don't have to
measure how deep that well is I mean to
love someone really like in a like in a
monogamous relationship it's kind of
like there's this like third entity
that you're serving you're not serving
the person you're serving the
relationship and then when you can get
on the same what Aubry was talking about
when you get on the same page on what
your relationships uh mission is like
that's a beautiful thing to serve and
you can't give it
enough love I think you can always give
that relationship love and some people
like to do it in a non-monogamous way
and that's okay too
right under a minute hey
so TK let's let's expand on this because
Iran and I have radically different
views on this and I think it's okay I
think it's actually helpful and maybe
even insightful for the audience because
I don't see a separate relationship I
think there is no such thing as a
relationship whether you are in a
monogamous relationship or a
non-monogamous relationship there isn't
a separate thing
that is just a word that allows us it's
a it's a signpost when I'm driving down
the 101 to get to Los Angeles I see a
sign that says Los Angeles 4 million 100
372 whatever people
and that's fine it's a sign post but
that sign itself is not actually Los
Angeles and if I were to mistake that
sign for loss oh there's Los Angeles
because it says Los Angeles on the side
and so when we're talking about a
relationship I don't see that there's
some sort of third entity here I see it
as I arrive and this other person
arrives Ryan I have a relationship only
in so far as how we interact with one
another and it could be daily weekly
monthly yearly whatever I have
relationships with people I I talk to
once a year you know I have a good
friend back in Ohio we'll talk once or
twice a year and there is some sort of
we're in relationship but there's not a
third entity for me the way that I see
it and he sees it differently yeah and
he sees it in a way that's helpful for
him exactly and that way isn't helpful
for me right and you know I think you're
getting caught up in the definition of a
relationship which I know we hate
getting caught up in definitions but the
word relationship for me is more of an
ethereal thing and really when he when
Aubry was talking about that wholeness
level
like that's what I'm talking about
because there isn't this like I'm going
to do something for you you do something
for me we're in this together we're with
each other it's thick and thin it's like
what are we both serving together and
that's really
um what relationship means to me and we
use metaphors all the time to help us
understand different things and yes the
third entity might make sense for me and
it may not make sense for you and that's
okay I mean it makes Josh wrong but
that's okay
by the way I love when people talk about
definitions I have never at any point in
my life ever been irritated or
inconvenienced when someone pressed me
for a definition or felt the need to
articulate their own because for me
definitions aren't dogmas they're not
Commandments that we have to obey all
definitions even even the ones in the
dictionary are simply descriptions
created by human beings of what some
people have meant when they use a word
and when we communicate with one another
it's helpful to know what we're talking
about so if you tell me I mean this even
if that's not my definition well it's
okay now I know what you mean by that
word and we won't waste any valuable
time having disagreements over things
that we actually have a shared
understanding over so yeah I think
talking about definitions is one of the
most underrated underdone things in
conversation seriously what did it for
me was when Bill Clinton was like Define
the word the was it the is
what is the definition of this to you
I'm like oh boy let's give him 60
seconds otherwise he'll talk all day
TK Coleman ladies and gentlemen oh man
love does not create the limits love is
that which creates through the limits
love isn't about artificially imposing
constraints on people in the name of
romance in the name of friendship in the
name of family love is about accepting
acknowledging and appreciating and
affirming
the constraints that are already there
and then figuring out a way how can I be
authentically me and how can I support
you in your quest to be authentically
you as we work together to co-create the
most beautiful experience we can within
the context of what we call relationship
that's what Love's all about yeah
give me 60 seconds Prof
and then we'll unpack it together the
three of us
clean to love
clinging to love is like clinging to
water
the harder you clinch the faster it
disappears we've all been in a
relationship with someone where
something is a bit off maybe they don't
feel the same way they used to feel
about me oh what's wrong oh TK please
tell me what what's wrong hmm and then I
cling Tighter and Tighter and Tighter
until what happens I start to strangle
you I actually strangle the love out of
the relationship if I try to cling to
water that's in my hand I open my hand
and none is left if I cling to a
relationship and I cling Tighter and
Tighter and Tighter I open my hand to
realize oh
the love is gone because of my clenching
because of my clinging because of my
attachment those attachments aren't love
attachment gets in the way of love it
blocks love and the way that we can love
someone is to cease clinging to them
because then you can actually see them
for who they are and that's what love is
um man what you just said is so
important
um because there are these different
stages of a relationship there's like
that lust that you first have and then
Aubry was talking about it that starts
to wane people don't know what to do and
they cling to that lust because they
don't know how to evolve their love with
their partner and um yeah and what
you're saying is really encouraging
people to not cling to the love they
wish they had and cling to What Love
Actually is in the moment with whoever
they're with yeah we're going to talk a
lot more about Open relationships coming
up on the private podcast we're gonna
check in with the patreon a live stream
in a moment as well but first real quick
for right here right now here's one
thing that's going on in the life of the
minimalist did you know over on patreon
we have three different minimalism
series we have five episodes of
something called relationship with less
last uh well a couple years ago now when
we released our book love people use
things I did this five part series and I
just sort of walk through our
relationship with less these different
relationships that we have in our lives
and so when people are always asking
what does this have to do with
minimalism what does this have to do
with minimalism yeah yeah I will show
you and in fact there's an entire
five-part series TK was actually present
for one of those as well you can find
all five of those over at patreon.com
the minimalist also five episodes of
minimalism today I turned myself into a
therapist for five little episodes where
I called up patrons on the phone and we
just talked about whatever they were
struggling with yeah hey what are you
struggling with right now some people
with stuff some people with
relationships some people was past
trauma whatever it was let's break that
down together and also during the uh the
pandemic we had 50 quarantine
conversations including one one of my
favorites with uh Dan Savage my favorite
sex advice columnist he's a great
podcaster The Savage Love podcast where
he talks about monogamy and non-monogamy
relationship ships and sex advice and we
did a conversation with him over there
patreon.com the minimals you can find
all 50 of those quarantine conversations
five episodes of minimalism today five
episodes of relationship with less and
of course our weekly maximal episodes
over there speaking of patreon Alabama
let's check in with the patreon live
stream what do you got for us we have a
question here from Amber how do you
bring up the subject of wanting to
expand into an open relationship with a
partner you've been with for several
years let's start by identifying how not
to talk about it quite often the things
that are most fraught the most stressful
the most worrisome we will bring them up
at the most inopportune times
we can all think about a time that we
had in our lives where it's like this
thing's really stressed me out it's way
into my mind I've got this mental
clutter but I'm gonna wait two minutes
before my wife's trying to run out the
door
she's grabbing the purse the daughter's
over here hey uh sweetheart can I talk
to you about opening the relationship
I just want to uh I just want to throw
that out there you think about it and
then we'll talk about it later
why are you on your way to work oh my
goodness now the opposite the opposite
of that is also true quite often because
there's never the absolute perfect time
to talk about these difficult
conversations what happens we never talk
about it and so quite often what I do is
I set a deadline for myself hey I know
this is a really important conversation
that I want to have with my wife with TK
with Ryan whoever it might be right I
want to have this difficult conversation
now we're in the middle of a podcast
right now probably be a terrible time
for me to have this conversation I'm
gonna call it my wife in fact when we
were recording earlier with uh Aubry
during the private podcast I wrote
something down that was revelatory for
me I mean I'm not even ready to talk
about it yet and so if I'm not ready to
talk about it it's obviously not the
most opportune time but there will be a
time that I need to talk about it so I
have some sort of deadline I need to
talk to this to my wife about this by
the end of the month and then what is
the most opportune time within that time
frame that's what's important there'll
never be the perfect time but I'll find
the most ideal time to talk about this
somewhere before that deadline that's
right and where you have the
conversation is also as important as
when you have the conversation because
in the same way you point out there's no
perfect time to have it but there are
some horrible times to have it there's
no perfect place to have the
conversation but there are some horrible
places to have it you don't want to
break this out at Starbucks you want to
be like hey I just want to spend some
time together today and you know go over
a few things and then you get in the
middle of Starbucks and it's crowded and
there's a bunch of people around and
you're putting the pressure on them to
have a reaction that is both honest and
also respectful towards you in this
public space and I'm not saying that
you're thinking about having it in
Starbucks but where you have the
conversation is also important
um the other thing I would say is I
believe that it's helpful to give people
the space to mentally prepare for a
conversation of this nature even if
it creates a little tension leading into
it one way you can do that is you can
write an email or a letter and you can
say I'm putting it in writing because I
want you to have the space to react but
this is something that I want to discuss
a little bit more and you can give them
some context if you don't want to
document it put it in writing that's
totally cool another thing is to say
without having too much time to wait
like I really need to talk about some
things that are really pressing on my
heart it's like super important to me
that we can be able to sit down and
discuss now that's going to make them
nervous that's gonna oh is everything
okay is everything all right
but at least when you have this
conversation they know this is the thing
that's been weighing on your mind and
they're like mentally ready to be very
attentive and to listen and to and to
discuss versus you know just like hey we
need to spend some more time together
and then you're walking around at
Disneyland or you're sitting out at a
restaurant and boom they're not mentally
prepared for it those will just be a
couple of bits of perspective I throw
into the pot yeah I mean
the question that I would ask this
Patron is do you feel like you can just
tell your partner this like do you feel
comfortable enough to just go to them
and say this and if not there's not
necessarily anything wrong with that but
that's the preface I would give it's
like why don't you feel like you can go
to your partner and talk to them about
this and so maybe start there before you
send them an email hey I want to talk
about opening up a relationship which
there is a way to ease into it there's a
way that you could ease into this and
open it right up to that conversation
however
there's a deeper problem right now in
that relationship if she feels like she
just she there's no way her partner
would want to talk about this and would
just put up a wall instantly yeah and
also I think it's important to keep in
mind here from what you're both saying
here
there are some best practices I use in
my own life that I didn't even realize I
necessarily use them it's just part of
my difficult conversation practice you
know I have to have a bunch of difficult
conversations Ryan and I've been having
difficult conversations for 32 years now
yeah and we had to have one recently but
I always sit down and write out this is
my process I'm not prescribing it to
anyone else Bex and I had to have a
really difficult conversation about a
month ago and I sat down and wrote pages
and Pages not so I could communicate
those pages to him to Orion or to Bex or
whomever and I was like hey here's my
difficult conversation read it actually
what it was one page for me because he
knows that's about all I can handle
it was a tweet a sub tweet right but no
what I what I'll do is I'll write it out
so I better understand what I actually
want to communicate what am I struggling
with where is the discontent where did
it arise from where do we go from here
these are some important questions
questions I have to ask myself what does
the ideal version of us look like going
forward if this current version is no
longer serving us maybe it served us for
a period of time but it's no longer
serving us I want to be really clear on
what the new version of us looks like so
we can have that conversation the only
way I can do that is if I sit down and I
write pages and pages and scroll across
stuff out and I really go through the
exercise of understanding what my own
perspective is because right now it's
just this emotional weight on my heart
and I've got all this mental clutter
because of it and then I can react in
strange ways I could be sad I could be
angry I could be resentful as opposed to
okay let's understand where those
emotions emanate from we're gonna get
back to the live stream we got a bunch
more questions coming up here from
Alabama what do you got for us first
here's a minimalist Insight from one of
our listeners a quick note on this
Insight this is from Connor Habib I just
did his podcast it was one of the best
conversations I've had and he had a
beautiful Insight we'll even talk about
this in depth on the private podcast
here is Conor Habib
hi guys this is Connor Habib and I just
wanted to say a few things about the
open relationship monogamy thing I think
first I just want to talk about
intention and awareness when we have an
open relationship because we're afraid
to commit or when we have a monogamous
relationship because we're insecure
about uh losing our partner to someone
else then we're not making a decision
about either relationship style we're
just sort of compulsively acting I'm not
making a judgment on that I'm just
saying that seems to happen a lot the
awareness and the intention is something
that I'd really like to pay attention to
in figuring out what's good or what's
bad I want to just be clear here and say
I'm not saying that awareness excuses
everything or automatically means that
you're doing something good people say
they're aware of things all the time to
dismiss bad or compulsive behaviors or
behaviors that we don't even have to
call them bad we can just say that um
aren't really in that person's Integrity
however you can't really have intention
and freedom without a sense of awareness
so awareness is a really high principle
because it leads to Freedom which is one
of the highest principles and therefore
it can lead to a real intentional kind
of love I think one of the main reasons
to level a critique at monogamy more
than open relationships is that
especially for heterosexual couples
monogamy is the default and monogamy is
the default in most cultural
conversations and most forms of art love
songs movies novels whatever so monogamy
becomes the unthinking default
I think it might be sort of more
instructive to think of monogamy as a
certain type of perversion the most
widespread form of perversion I don't
mean that by the way in necessarily a
negative way I just think that if we
view wedding rings for instance as this
highly public s m toy that people feel
like they can wear into public without
anyone commenting on it you can kind of
get a sense of what I mean after all you
have this band Around Your Finger that
same uh my partner controls who I am
allowed to look at or talk to how I'm
allowed to touch another person or even
fantasize about another person much less
actually have sex with others in fact
this ring here is symbolizing complete
sexual restraint and control and a
certain set of real boundaries and it
also signals to everybody else who I'm
having sex with publicly
so I think that we can view monogamy
that way and the problem isn't that it's
a perversion that's fine it's just that
it's somehow recognized as being outside
of the field of being highly sexualized
outside of the field of uh being just
another kind of Kink and when we start
viewing it that way we can sort of level
the playing field because what we
usually try to do is say oh well an open
relationship can be just as loving and
fulfilling as monogamy that is true but
we should also flip the script there and
say
you know monogamy can also be
um perverse and it can also be a hyper
arousal mechanism and all that kind of
stuff because we really need to actually
smooth out the playing field to allow
people to say I want to make an
intentional choice about the kind of
relationship I want to be in I want to
actually explore discuss think about
reflect contemplate I want to meditate
even on these relationship choices with
my partner and you know make a real
decision anyway that's just a little bit
there
um thanks for uh asking me to do this
bye
all right y'all that's our minimal
episode for today we'll see you on
patreon for the full three hour maximal
edition of Episode 385 which includes
answers to a bunch more questions like
what do monogamy and open relationships
have to do with minimalism isn't that
just kind of relationship hoarding we'll
talk about relationship hoarding because
I think that's a real thing is monogamy
natural or is it a result of cultural
conditioning how can I be in an open
relationship without being judged by my
friends family and Community plus a
million more questions for Aubry Marcus
and the minimalists also this week we
have a private minimalist home tour one
of our lovely listeners sent in this
eclectic home tour it's unlike any
living room or dining room you have ever
seen we also have a minimalism story
written 100
by chat GPT I think you'll be surprised
by that one and also we have an added
value segment for you a song about
monogamy and much much much more
about less
and if you want to hear all that check
out the minimalist private podcast
patreon.com the minimalist or click the
link in the description to subscribe and
get your personal link so that our
weekly maximal episodes play and your
favorite podcast app you also get access
to all of our podcast archives all the
way back to episode zero zero one and if
you're still on the fence here's a
testimonial from one of our lovely
patreon supporters Justin says thank you
for everything you do with each private
podcast episode every time I listen it
opens my mind to a different way of
living you even have my 16 year old son
hooked I guess it's better to be hooked
on minimalism than meth right that's
what the billboard says
big thanks to Aubry and Marcus for
joining us today you can check out his
new course by the way it's called from
solo to Sacred Union that's at
aubrymarcus.com relationships we'll put
a link to that in the show notes and you
can check out his podcast the Aubry
Marcus podcast and if you leave here
today with just one message please
let it be this
love people and use things
the opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
peace
every little thing
you need
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without it
foreign
every little